welcome to this free webinar on
omics logic data science in today's
session
our team will be sharing information
examples
and an overview of omics logic training
resources
designed for anyone to learn data
science for biomedical data
as seen in application to projects
sourced from
current topics in biomedical research
my name is beepsha biswas and i i'm the
omixlogic community manager
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users
that are part of this bioinformatics
community
managed by pine biotech let me start by
introducing
buying biotech the company behind omix
logic
and share with you details about the
upcoming omics logic programs and
explain
how the training resources we will be
discussing
and using through this entire training
omits logic program for bioinformatics
training was developed
in collaboration between pine biotech
and the tauber bioinformatics research
center
what we will discuss today and
throughout this program
is a result of hard work by an amazing
team
led by company co-founders dr
alfred tuber who comes from a medical
background and has
extensive expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
inflammation
and has been recognized internationally
for his generous support
of many research projects and
initiatives
that support data science training and
applications
in medicine dr leonid brodsky is the
director of the jobber bioinformatics
research center
at university of haifa and is an expert
in bioinformatics and biostatistics
he has numerous publications in
mathematics and bioinformatics
and over the course of his career has
developed multiple novel algorithmic
approaches
to biomedical data analysis the rest of
the team
includes experts in bioinformatics
computer science
and some of our team will be presenting
today as well
over the course of the past several
years our team
has been collaborating with a number of
academic institutions
around the world that have participated
in content evaluation
review and project design as a result
the omics logic programs have been
thoroughly evaluated
and are known to lead to excellent
outcomes
importantly the programs are designed
to support students with minimal
bioinformatics background
including biology and biomedical study
majors
as well as faculty interested in
bioinformatics
data science and biomedical research
the goal of the omics logic programs is
to provide
training in bioinformatics enabling
independent
research guided by mentors in peer
example
developing a growing community with
shared passion for data-driven research
and appreciation of citizen science
enabling students clinicians and faculty
of all backgrounds to develop novel and
independent research using latest
technology
in life and data sciences
the program is designed to offer an
introduction to statistical analysis and
machine learning
and a broad overview of technologies and
project
examples to learn about and develop
practical data science skills
using user-friendly cloud technologies
as well as
r and python coding after completing
this program
you will gain experience with methods
for analysis of big data
and data wrangling essential skills for
buying for magicians as well as those
interested in other types of non-biology
related research using data analysis
the program is designed for students
starting from the
undergraduate level to faculty and
researchers
from both biology and clinician
backgrounds
can participate to learn more about data
science in biomedical research
in the upcoming omics logic program you
will have
the opportunity to interact and
collaborate with an international team
of
experts specialized in the application
of data science to biological data sets
let me introduce you to the main speaker
of today's session
we have dr harpreet kaur who is a
certified omix logic trainer
and an expert bioinformatician and will
guide the hands-on
sessions and assist participants with
projects
and analysis during the program her
area of specialization is cancer
genomics and machine learning
dr mohit mazumdar is our omics logic
project mentor
and an expert in big data computational
analysis
dr mazumdar has a phd in computational
biology
and over 10 years of experience working
with industry
and academia ilia brodsky
is the co-founder and ceo of pinebiotic
in his current role he has
extensive experience working together
with industry and academic partners
that are applying multi-omics
integration
and bioinformatics to a variety of
biotechnology
and clinical applications i will pass it
on to elia to talk about the
increasing significance of data science
in biomedical research and introduce you
to the type of challenges we will be
addressing
in this upcoming program over to you
elia
thank you very much pizza
my name is ilya broski as was mentioned
and i'm one of the
co-founders in pine biotech and i'm
happy to share with you today a little
bit of a perspective
about big data in life sciences and also
talk about how this program is going to
help you understand
the role of data science and the
significance of skills
of related to data science as well as
the application to different types of
projects
so as you know over the past 20 to 30
years there has been a phenomenal growth
in the adoption of high
technologies like next generation
sequencing in research biotechnology
and even in clinical practice these
technologies produce
an enormous growth of publicly available
omics data
and we can leverage that data to
understand
how we can analyze and study biology
at a completely new level however this
trend has also produced a big data
problem
and that precludes many biologists and
clinicians from gleaning knowledge from
these data
regarding the nature of malignant
processes and the relationship between
clinical phenotypes and their molecular
drivers
but what we know is that the same
technology
like next generation sequencing can be
used to explore the roles relationships
and
actions of the various types of
molecules that make up the cells of an
organism
different types of information can be
extracted from these omics data types
and the high throughput sequencing
technology is just one of the
technologies
that allows us to study how these
molecular processes happen
at tissue organism or even single cell
levels
most of these data types are generated
randomly
at high speeds and producing large
unstructured data sets to process
and structure them they require complex
computational data
processing a procedure that will convert
the unstructured data to structure data
which can be visualized and analyzed
statistically
commonly these types of data sets are
used to study
a variety of factors including dna
variation
gene expression variation protein
abundance levels
and even composition properties of
microbial communities
all of these are very different types of
omics data
however we will learn to explore and
mine them for patterns
using some standard tools that come from
the field of data science
or computational biology for example
we'll look at how
gene expression patterns can be
associated with
clinical phenotypes and help identify
what's called molecular biomarkers that
are used for diagnostics
and therapy selection we will also talk
about how new discoveries based on
analysis of such data
include a better understanding of
complex diseases
at their subcellular level as well as
allow for target identification for
novel drug design
and repurposing we will take a variety
of research examples
and learn about the logic behind each
types of onyx data
that is used to study cancer tissue
biology
and the microbiome we will also look
at the full overview of data science and
biomedical research to understand how
different stages of analysis
work together to help define the
hypothesis or the question that we're
asking
as well as prepare the data for
meaningful application of machine
learning
to practical challenges we will also
have the chance to see how
different data mining and machine
learning or classification methods
are used to study patterns understand
grouping between data objects by feature
similarity
and how prediction can be achieved
by training different types of machine
learning and
evaluating the model accuracy to
understand
how we can rely on such predictions
we will also speak about making machine
learning models more transparent
and easily explainable when we present
the results of our analysis
two collaborators that might come from a
clinical or
biological background now let me pass it
on
to continue speaking about one such
project example
led by dr harpreet kaur who is going to
be the omixlogic trainer
so she can introduce herself and talk
about her research
experience over to you her breed
thank you ilya so just let me share my
supreme
so about me my name is khadri scott
and i have done my phd in bioinformatics
from csir institute of microbial
technology
and gnu neutrality and i have done my
master's in molecular biology and
biochemistry from gndu amnesty india
and i have done my graduation in
biotechnology
from punjabi university india
so about my research background i have
experience in the bioinformatics
cancer genomics machine learning
biomarker discovery
and then resource development on
different aspects of
human health and i have most of my
research work is framed
in the 14 research publications with
having
more than 200 google scholar citations
and for my different research projects i
have got
yes a junk investigator award an inc
junk researcher award and i have
received
my doctoral fellowship from the csir
that is council of scientific and
industrial research
let me give you an illustrations how we
can proceed
for research problems in data science
with my own research experience i will
give you
examples from my phd research process
so my phd is focused on computer aided
identification of genetic biomarker
for the diagnosis and the prognosis of
the liver cancer
so let me uh let me tell you
what inspired me to take liver cancer as
my
doctor research problem
cancer is considered as one of the major
concerns worldwide
as according to the global current
report 2018
uh there are nearly 18 million people
that are diagnosed with cancer every
year
and out of which 9.6 million people are
dying
because of the cancer per year
so one of the six that is only due to
the cancer
among the cancers particularly the liver
cancer
it is considered as sixth major cancer
in terms of the metabolic
in terms of the number of the new
incidences
that taking place every year and in
terms of the
mortality rate it is considered as the
fourth major cancer
that contribute nearly more than eight
percent of the
uh mortality rate that is only due to
the cancer
so to proceed a research problem
first of all the literature and we have
gone through what are the major
challenges and what are the major
problems that are associated with the
liver cancer
so by extensive uh literature research
we found that there is three or the firs
uh four major issues that are associated
for the liver cancer
with the liver cancer that eventually
results in the
low uh tour prognosis in literature we
found that uh there is
a very poor survivor five-year survival
rate for the liver cancer
that is nearly 18 so what were the
factors that
affecting its high mortality rate
so once we observe that really the first
problem is that it's inaccurate uh
inaccurate cancer diagnosis or cancer
prediction
so we have observed that as
hepatocellular carcinoma that is
hcc it is one of the major
form of the liver cancer where cancer is
derived from the hepatocyte
it nearly contributes 75 percent of the
cases to the liver cancer
the second method primary liver cancer
that is cholengiocarcinoma
which derived from the cell lining the
wilder and
literature indicated that there is
a lot of the high mortality rate
is due to its inaccurate diagnosis so we
understand that there is need to
identify the methods or the biomarkers
that can predict cancer with more
accuracy
then we have observed that in the
literature if cancer is diagnosed
at early stage then there are a large
number of the
treatment options are available so they
become limited
if cancer detected at the late stage
or get uh it or you will detect a cancer
at advanced stage
so the next problem that we have
observed
that there is need to identify a
genomics biomarker
that can predict cancer at early stage
as possible
the third factor that contributes to the
high mortality rate of the liver cancer
that is there is tumor reoccurrencing
taking place
so we have understand that we need to
identify uh
genomics or omix biomarkers that can
identify the patients that are at high
risk
and the patients that are low risk so
accordingly
treatment options are available for
every kind of
therapeutic treatment for the particular
class of the faces
so with this background we have
asked major we have tried to
address this problem by asking four
major research questions first we want
to identify
omics bioma transcriptomics biomarker
that can classify scc from the normal
sample
so as i have already told you scc is one
of the major primary liver cancer
the second question we have tried to
address
that we should able to identify
transcriptomic signatures
that can predict clanger carcinoma
in comparison to the normal and the scc
samples
then our next research problem is
focused on the stage classification
where we want to identify multi-omics
biomarkers that include transcriptomics
as well as the methylation the ah based
signature
that can predict liver cancer at the
early stage
and in the last uh problem we have tried
to address
to identify multi-omics biomarkers
that include rna mi rna and the
methylation
that can stratify high risk and the low
risk
reoccurrence scc facing groups
so let me demonstrate one by one some of
these presets
so first in the first question we have
tried to identify
transcriptomics biomarkers that can
predict
scc from the multiple platforms
so for this we have collected 32 data
sets
from the public repositories that is
geo and the gdc data portal
so for all these 32 data sets are
processed using different profiling
techniques that is illumina
as linked after matrix and high
throughput further
we have divided these data set into
three categories
one for the training data set the second
for the differential gene expression
analysis third for the external
validation cohort
so to reduce the genes from large scale
as there are
20 000 genes are present in any kind
of transcriptomics data so to
filter out the important genes we have
performed differential gene expression
analysis
on 27 27 datasets which have nearly
1200 xcc samples and nearly 950
assists in non-tumor normal samples and
first of all we have performed
differential gene expression analysis
on each of these datasets using wilcoxon
and welch t
test so we have obtained 26
genes that point to or that one to be
significant differentially expressed
in all these 27 datasets so then to
develop a prediction model or to confirm
the prediction power of
these genes we have kept a data set
trading
where we have nearly 250 hcc samples
and 250 normal samples
so then we have uh on the training data
set out of these 26 genes
we have applied various features
collection approaches
including recursive feature reduction
approach where
one by one gene is eliminated the uh
whose deletion is not affecting the
performance of a particular prediction
model
so eventually we have obtained the three
genes
so based on the three genes that include
fcn3
1b prc one so
based on these three genes we have
developed machine learning
prediction model using various
classifiers
like svc rvf random forest
extra tree lda etc on the training
datasets
then the most important problem
important step
you must able to validate your
prediction model so you must able to
evaluate the performance of your
biomarkers
on external validation cohorts so for
this we have four external validation
cohorts
where we have nearly uh 850 xc samples
and nearly 500 normal samples so
performance of these
models based on these three gene based
signature
is evaluated on all these four external
validation cohorts
so we have observed a prediction model
based on these three genes
able to discriminate fcc and the normal
samples
within accuracy nearly 97 and
sensitivity and specificity is more than
90 percent in
each of the data sets in its training as
well as
external validation cohort so after
assessing its diagnostic potential
then we want to assess its prognostic
potential we want to understand
whether these genes able to uh
predict the prognosis of the patients
that is whether it can predict the
high uh patient at uh have higher
survival rate or patient that have lower
survival rate
for this we have taken two cohorts
one is from the tcva that is the cancer
genome at least
for the liver cancer the other is gsc
one four
five two zero cohort from that we have
obtained from the
geo and uh in the tcga we have nearly
350 samples and the jio cohort we have
nearly 220 samples so then we have
performed univariate survival analysis
to access uh to assess its prognostic
potential
here we have considered two types of
survival data
that is overall survival and
disease-free survival
this digital survival is also called uh
called as
reoccurrence freeze survival so
eventually we have
uh we have confirmed that
all these three genes able to uh
significantly stratify
high and the low risk of survival these
groups of scc person
with an hr value that is hazard ratio
more than 1.5 and p value less than 0.05
eventually all these prediction models
were
integrated in form of a web server that
is called accessible
so this paper is published in the
january 2020
in the frontier in genetics
and this is the web server where we have
integrated
uh the all these prediction model to
predict the scc samples
that is called assessing it
in the second problem we have focused on
focused on the second major liver cancer
type that is calendulo carcinoma
cleanser carcinoma as i have already
told you
is the cancer that derives from the
cells lining the wilderness
so here we have focused on identifying
the transcriptomic specific
signature that can classify
cca from xcc as well as the normal
sample
for this we have obtained nearly nine
data sets
from the jio first of all we have
pre-processed
these data access and then based on our
uh
some of the uh the data set next we have
performed differential gene expression
analysis
in the differential x gene expression
analysis we have identified nearly 8800
genes
that want to be significant
differentially expressed in cca
and the normal samples and we have
identified there are
229 genes that want to be significant
differentially expressed
in cca and the ssc circle then we have
compared all these genes
and we have found that there are 202
genes that were found to be significant
differentially expressed
in the both the classes that is cca
versus normal as well as cpa versus
scc then to further reduce the number of
the features
from this signature set as you can know
uh it is difficult
practically difficult to design a
biomarker with
such a set large set of genes so we have
applied various features selection and
creature reduction approaches
including simple threshold uh svcl1
weka etc then based on the selected set
of features
we have applied various machine learning
algorithms
and here we have applied different
machine learning algorithms to develop a
machine learning prediction model
on a training data set like extra 3
logistic regression random forest knn
ridge classifier perceptron etc
then performance of these multiple genes
is evaluated on validation external
validation cohorts
and we have here we have observed that
we found the three genes that that is
lamb c2 ita and c2
that can classify cca samples from the
normal
and the scc sample with an accuracy more
than ninety percent
thank you harpreet uh thank you very
much for um
sharing your background um uh
maybe you could also introduce
thank you so now let me introduce dr
mohit
uh who is our mentor uh
at pine bar tech
thank you dr harpreet for this wonderful
presentation so
let me share my screen
okay
so here we go so my name is mohit
mazumdar
i am one of the global representatives
of pine biotech
and my phd was focused on identification
and prediction of binding affinity
towards calcium for the protein
as a result i had to master data mining
and become proficient at predictive
modeling
our team ended up using combination of
amino acid features to train multiple
machine learning models
using a non-linear non-linear kernel
implemented in support vector machine
that was really fascinating in my
current role however
i am collaborating and working with
academia and industry to provide support
for bioinformatics education
and research i have 12 years of
experience
working and collaborating with pharma
healthcare industry to solve
high priority scientific questions
related to biomedical data analysis
and uh also bioinformatics capability
capacity building so
as elia mentioned
there has been a remarkable shift
over the last decade in the cost of
generating
these molecular measurements most
notably
uh if you think about dna sequencing but
also um i think the other omics
technologies like transcriptomics
proteomics and metabolomics so
most impacted by this change is the area
of
i guess genomic medicine where it is not
possible to move from
generating reference on you know
population level data
to producing data from individuals right
concurrently there has been advances
in developing a development of these new
algorithms
and tools to integrate and interpret
this kind of data so bioinformatics is
now playing a key role
in all healthcare industries and
especially the pharma industry
which is now uh i guess considering data
science and bioinformatics
a very important part of their portfolio
so uh i have a working experience uh
so if you can see in this survey you'll
find out that
ai and big data has the biggest impact
right
in health care and pharma so
however to understand this application
and to be able to find information from
this big data
it's important to learn about the
analysis strategy
and and get experience or working on
real data sets together with our
research collaborators
from top universities uh we actually
[Music]
we have created and prepared projects
for you
that takes you through a project-based
approach
where where we take data sets from high
impact publication and use them for you
know
practical exercises it is difficult to
imagine
what the biomedical industry will look
like in a few years time
i'm sorry about that
so yeah as i was telling you that it's
with all this data coming from different
sources and people are publishing every
day
it's difficult to imagine exactly how
this all
how this industry will shape up inside
but
it is certain that there is a surge of
biological data that is
flowing uh all this time
this increase in data will form large
innovative research projects
so one of the research projects that is
uh that we wanted to talk to you ab that
i wanted to tell you about
is the international human cell atlas
initiative 10
that aims to create comprehensive
reference map
to all the human cells and also devices
apps wearables and implantable
technologies
so in our data science program we will
learn about these analysis strategies
and methods and we will learn about
hands-on experience working on real data
sets
for example this is a project that
describes modeling
cancer precision medicine so the
application in cancer the application
and infectious diseases
we have projects spanning from
agriculture biotechnology
agribiotechnology and uh neurosciences
so we have wherever the application is
so there are plenty of
uh resources from where you can learn in
this program
that we have prepared for you so with
this information uh let me pass it on to
miss bieb chaviswas
to talk about important uh deadlines and
uh and program registration options
thank you uh everyone and uh it's
to you much dr mohit
yeah i will be showing everyone uh
different ways you can access this
program
so the data science program is going to
be starting
on 12th of october it is a one month
program and every day the sessions will
start at 9 a.m cst which is the same
time where
this session also started
we will combine online sessions
self-guided study materials and
practical assignments
for an immersive experience that has
proven to be effective
in our well-known and respected omics
logic programs
the program theoretical materials are
found on
edut bioinfo
and i will just give you an overview of
how you can
access these different resources on the
platform once you have the registration
completed so
this is the link to the platform from
where you can register
to the different courses and i will be
posting the different links
in the chat here
so if you go to this page you can click
on get started or pricing
to finish your registration and we have
three different
options that you can choose from we have
the beginner option
that covers all of the different
resources that are going to be available
for the program
we have an intermediate option that
offers you
mentor support and one-on-one mentor
support
in addition to the basic resources and
we have
advanced membership for those of you who
are
interested in working on a long term
project with us
because this gives you access to
more than um one membership option which
means that you can go beyond
one month program and get an additional
30 days more to work on your project and
also interact with our intern
and you can also request for
scholarships and discounts which are
available
please email us at marketing at pine dot
bio i'll be putting my email
in the chat marketing at pine dot bio
for any kind of request regarding
scholarships and discounts
and once you finish your registration on
this page you see there is a
coupon code here which i will be sharing
later on
and you can request for those codes as
well
then you will have access to what we
call the edut bio info
so the edud bioinfo is the main platform
for where
you can access the courses and
this is the forum in the edut by info
platform
so from this forum you see that we have
a few topics posted here this is like a
classroom
every participant of the omits logic
data science program will have
access to this forum from where they can
use the forum to interact with us and
with each other
access the different courses so if you
go under courses you see
these courses and you can see the
different courses that are part of the
program
and also courses which are more relevant
like biomedical data visualization in
r so you have access to these courses as
part of the program
and also projects
and there are some of these scholarship
options that you can look at
so please visit this link if you want to
apply for scholarship
and let us know you will also get
access to what we call the server tbio
info platform
and the code omix logic platform these
two platforms are also
a part of this program and will be
freely available for you to use during
the entire
length of this one month data science
program
and to introduce this program i want to
invite
elia again uh to give you all a short
demo
elia over to you thank you so much
everyone
thank you victor so um as mitch
mentioned uh
the program is intended to allow you to
develop
skills that cover a broad
application of data science starting
from
processing of different types of omnics
data
and all the way to visualization machine
learning and statistical analysis
all of these are equally important as
you think about
applications in cancer biology
as well as other types of biomedical
challenges
so i'll briefly introduce three
resources the first one is going to be
the server platform
and this platform allows us to analyze
different types of omics data using
a guided and visual interface
that gives access to anyone without any
technical background
to complicated tools and
different types of visualization so let
me
first of all explain how that works
inside
each one of the sections you have an
interface that packages
these uh public domain uh
published algorithms and provides
a guided flow of data with color-coded
maps
explained methods that work with a
variety of input and output formats
and help you create reproducible
workflows
as a result you get to interact with the
data
without having the computational
infrastructure
needed to process these huge data sets
so let me briefly give you an overview
of what that really looks like so this
is the link
that you can follow to find this
platform
here you can see different types of
data and different types of integration
modeling and analysis tools
so i'm going to just briefly show you
one of the demos
each time that you select an option and
there will be an explanation
that guides you through the logic of
analysis
an important component that is
oftentimes
overlooked on other solutions because
they
expect the user to know all of the
inputs and outputs of each method
and be able to navigate the process of
analysis
from an expert point of view so this
really eliminates that expertise
requirement and allows you to use the
platform and
get results that are structured and
ready
for analysis so this platform will be
useful for
processing big data accessing tools
that are difficult to install and
difficult to
run in a command line but it will give
everybody a quick sense of how to apply
these types of methods
to large negative generation sequencing
data sets
and we'll see different types of outputs
and factors
required to understand how to build such
bioinformatics pipelines
the second resource that i would like to
mention
and give you a little overview is what
we call
code playground so this code
playground is intended to get you
started
with coding in both r and python
interacting with the prepared data sets
after they have been processed you can
actually start
loading them visualizing them doing
statistical analysis
and an introduction to machine learning
so obviously processing omix data is
going to be very important
in a variety of life sciences and
biology research
not only to biomedical data sets but we
will primarily use examples with bio
with biomedical significance because
we believe that data science is very
impactful in that area so let me show
you
how the code omixlogic
platform actually works in many of these
pipelines one of the outputs that you
will receive
is a package a code with the input data
that you will later on can use to
analyze
in our and in python so this is the link
as beeps are already placed in the chat
this is the link to
the omixlogic code playground
and the omixlogic playground is actually
free to register so any one of you
can go on this link and create an
account
for free once you are in
this um once you are in
the platform and registered you can
start with
very basics for those of you that have
minimal background in
r and python we go from the very basics
so for example you can see here
loading data some basic visualization
reading dna sequences dna replication
reverse complements and r and other
topics as well so you can really go
through the basics the
ones that have a star are premium
courses
so you'll get access to those as a part
of this program
or you can actually buy a very
affordable subscription
for just ten dollars a month and explore
some of these different types of
some of these different types of courses
now in the context of this particular
program
we are going to be using a little bit
more advanced
type of analyses so i'll just give you a
brief overview
here's an example of what's called
principal component analysis
so before you start going into the
coding you really get to understand
where this fits in in the overall
data analysis process
and you get to understand the data set
that was generated
on the t bioinfo platform that we just
looked at so here you can see the data
set
it's a gene expression matrix with the
names of samples
in your header and the names of
genes here in your row names
and what principal component analysis
seeks to
provide you with is an ability to
simplify
the number of features which are
thousands
to a small combination of vectors
in this multi-dimensional space and
using the projection
onto this space you can understand
differences between samples or objects
in your data set
and study the relationship between
groups of different samples so as you
can see here
you get to learn the code this is a code
in r
so we load some libraries and then the
input
we specify the input file
load this file and convert it to a
matrix
and analyze this matrix with
a principal component analysis
library uh from the autoplot
library so then you actually get to try
this code yourself
so here this code could be run right
inside the browser you don't need to
install anything on your computer
so you can see here that we have a data
set
um and we can just press on run
and once you press on run it launches a
cloud-based script
that performs whatever is right here
in your code block so you can see that
we already finished
and there is a an output here
in the console as well as some visual
outputs
and so based on the these visual outputs
you can see that
some samples are far away from the
others
and here you can see how
the different types of expression data
is
uh distributed and also you can
understand the significance of the
different principal components
so obviously this is just a starting
point to start understanding
how the data could be visualized
based on all of the available data and
eventually we get to this kind of an
output which shows us that
actually these are breast cancer
subtypes
and they are different by groups so we
see a group of luminal samples
a group of basal samples and here we
have a group of
normal-like and clouding low
as you continue through these courses
they will
go from very simple like how to load
data
to interactive like this what we did to
eventually
challenges where you have to write your
own code from scratch
and analyze data sets that we discuss in
the program
all of this information is going to be
both in r and in python and we
do this so that you can actually have a
sense of how these two languages work
and develop some skills by practicing
these different basic
types of visualization and more and more
advanced types of data science methods
that are going to be important
for any area of research as you start
dealing with this kind of data
so when we go through this code
breakdown we really understand
what the code does and can practice what
it should
provide us with before you start
applying
this in your own environment your own
developer environment so we also go
through an introduction of how to set
that up
for python or for r what types of
libraries to include
what kinds of methods you should have
and as a result
for many of you not only will you
understand the syntax and read the code
to understand what is being done to the
different data sets
but also you'll be able to develop a
library of snippets of code
that are going to be very very useful if
you are
a student or if you are conducting
research
and regularly have the need
for different types of analyses that we
describe
and we use in this program
so again i wanted to remind everyone
that
the program itself will start on october
12th
this is coming up very soon so we have a
short win of opportunity to complete
your registration
as beeps and mentioned already we have a
number of
a number of research scholarships that
are available for those of you that are
interested
beeps has also provided a link and maybe
she'll put it again in the chat
for those of you that want to
participate in the program but really
require
a an assistant financial assistance
where we have several of those available
but let me briefly describe what we will
cover
in the program itself
so the first part of the program
in week one we are going to speak about
different types of omics data we'll
discuss
big data challenges and opportunities
which
many of those challenges have resulted
in
these pipelines to process data some of
them have an
impact on how we prepare the data for
analysis looking for batch effects and
outliers
and some of them are important to
understand the technologies producing
these data sets
so that we can incorporate their
specificity
to the downstream analysis and that's
why we'll talk about cleaning loading
and
processing these data sets and learning
exploratory data analysis so instead of
jumping into a full analysis it's
always important to understand what kind
of variation
is present what kind of information am i
able to get out of this data set
and what technical issues i need to
address before trying to run
a an analysis and we'll have some
hands-on sessions where we'll do
uh practical uh kind of use cases
for different types of methodologies now
in week two
we will start talking about machine
learning and artificial intelligence
we'll start from what's called data
mining so we'll discuss
unsupervised machine learning methods
like principal component analysis
as an example or clustering we'll talk
about how
different methods use different
assumptions about data
and what do we need to understand about
those assumptions to make sure that we
are using those
appropriately then we'll talk about
supervised machine learning or
classification
and when we talk about classification
we'll learn about methods like
discriminate analysis random forest and
decision
trees as well as support vector machines
and other types of machine learning
including deep learning
and we'll think about how those can be
applied
in the context of different project
examples that we've described
so far including cancer
including microbiome and including
infectious diseases so sequences of
viral genomes
so we really will think about how
these different methods are to be
applied
and we'll also think about how to
explore the models so how accurate
and how valid they are both from a
statistical perspective
but also from the perspective of biology
and biomedical applications now in the
last session we'll actually talk about
how to get results with machine learning
because really
it's not just about training a model and
always looking at the prediction there
are many different
use cases where different outputs from
these machine learning models could be
very useful
to extract information from
the data that we have and so it's very
important as you learn about these
different
types of methods different types of
applications of data science
to then consider a project of your own
so the program is designed to last for
about a month
and we have numerous participants that
have been able to use this time
to both learn and develop
an individual independent research
project
that will demonstrate how they can apply
these different types of methods to a
data set that is
interesting to them so we'll have a
number of sessions where we will
describe different projects read
publications
and explore publicly available data sets
that you can start leveraging for your
research
our previous participants have been able
to understand bioinformatics for the
first time
and learn how to apply data science
methods to their own research data set
so for example
olga udartseva who is a research
affiliate a postdoctoral student at
roswell park comprehensive cancer center
in new york
was able to benefit from this program
completing a variety of
courses and really understanding how
these different courses
show the application of bioinformatics
to pre-clinical data sets
and eventually how they can lead to
insights
about treating cancer patients and
diagnosing
different cancer patients
now we will we were also fortunate to
work with
a variety of participants uh beeps that
shared a link here to different project
examples that you can explore
how different people were able to uh use
the program to develop this
independent research and also we've
gotten some
important insights from our participants
about how our programs
are different from your standard courses
on coursera edx and other
types of online study platforms
so we were really kind of focused
on this research aspect and really
making sure that our materials are very
practical
and very applicable to independent
research
projects so this is a little overview
of the program that we are going to
start
on october 12th again the program is
going to be called
omics logic data science and it is
designed to introduce you to the
analysis of big data
to explain the role of bioinformatics
and life sciences
and to help you wrangle large data sets
and extract
meaningful information so that you can
do independent research in life sciences
using data science skills
at this point i would like to open this
uh discussion for any questions uh if
any of you have any specific questions
about the program itself or about any of
the topics presented
uh by dr mohit mazumdar or dr harpreet
kaur
about their experience and about the way
that they will leverage the examples
from their research
in the context of the training that is
provided in this data science program
elia there is a question from shreya so
she did ask that i am in my first year
of mbbs
and inclined towards bio for matrix i
missed studying mathematics
what should i do
uh well i'm not sure what is mpbs again
mbbs medicals
oh yeah so we have some experience
dealing with medical students we work
with georgetown university medical
center
and their program for systems medicine
and a lot of the participants of that
program go on to become
members of a medical school so what
we've seen
is that there is a tremendous
growth in data-driven insights
for diagnostics for treatment selection
for even understanding
different types of costs associated with
treatments
and so it's very important for medical
students to
learn about how data is going to be used
in the future of medicine
really driving the future of medicine to
become
more personalized as mentioned by
and more uh precise as mentioned by dr
harpitka or
when she described the biomarkers so we
really believe that this is an important
component of your
clinical future and if you are going to
be
exploring careers as a clinician
as a technician in a clinical lab as a
decision maker
from a health policy and
ethics standpoint i think these are very
important topics that are being
discussed actively
uh in the context of medicine how
what role does data and different types
of omix technologies and different types
of analysis methods
nih has the national institute of health
has a major push
to enable clinicians to leverage data
science
and to also understand the implications
of these types of
methods like machine learning and ai
and so i think it's very important to
consider both the ethical
and the clinical aspects of how these
methods work
okay any other questions
harshita we will be emailing you
regarding that we have a program
coming up on ngs and also we have uh
dedicated programs on rna-seq and
metagenomics starting in november
and december so i will email you those
details
uh does anyone have any other questions
to add
or you can also mention if you have any
specific
area
if you could address shia's question
would it be too late to start learning
bioinformatics
and data science after completing mbbs
well i think that the key here is to
really
be able to understand that
bioinformatics could be application of
bioinformatics and data science
or could be a degree to make you
a researcher in bioinformatics and data
science and these are two very different
uh kind of paths uh moving forward i
think as a clinician as someone that
wants to do research
with clinical data with patients
with biomedical topics you do not have
to be
a bioinformatician or a data scientist
but if you want to be a good clinician
and a good
researcher for biomedical projects you
do have to have
some mastery of data science and some
understanding of bioinformatics
because you will be required to deal
with data and make decisions based on
data
so how else will you be be effective at
that
if you don't understand data science and
bioinformatics
now the good thing is that you can do
this in an effective way
in parallel i believe with your mbbs
so you could really study short
term courses on data science
like the course that we are describing
today um
you can have a level of mastery that
allows you to start dealing with data
sets and as
these types of data sets come up in your
program you will
understand where else you need to
improve your skills
and where else you need to develop a
deeper understanding
of these types of analysis methods
potentially
preparing you for a future that is more
bioinformatics focused
and i've interacted and met with a
number of
researchers as well as industry
professionals and clinicians
that have md phds or that work in
industry like pharmaceutical companies
biotechnology companies
different clinical research centers and
even just clinicians in the areas of
oncology infectious diseases
that regularly rely on bioinformatics to
make decisions
and to conduct research even they
even though they do not have a formal
degree
in bioinformatics or data science now
did that answer your question
sram
you're welcome shreya and thank you elia
for answering the question
uh if we do not have any more question
then we would like to conclude today's
session
you can again reach out to us at any
time
marketing and find out bio is the email
id
please use it and reach out to us
we will be emailing anybody who has left
their email addresses with us
regarding all the details of the
upcoming programs
thank you so much for joining today
we'll see you at the session thank you